[Music]
2013 Hall of Fame ballot I believe
you're on this ballot I will be you okay
congratulations Sammy Sosa's on the
ballot Barry Bonds is on the ballot and
of course Roger Clemens is on the ballot
and those are three players that have
been linked to steroids what is your
opinion should they know not only should
they shouldn't get in you they shouldn't
get in you mean what would you do with
their records should their record of an
asterisk so you buy that you get rid of
them I think absolutely it's a slippery
slope and it's one of those
conversations that when you begin to
talk about details of how you'd go about
doing it people start the weigh-in with
different opinion well if you do this
and you do that you don't know when they
started if you cheated you're done and I
and it that you know it's not to say
that there's a purity about the Hall of
Fame because there's some really bad
people in the Hall of Fame there's
really bad people and all the Hall of
Fame's but if character and morals and
ethics don't matter then I'm not sure
what it stands for all right
[Applause]